[Musique]
moi j'aime que oui parce que d'un côté
découvrir la culture des autres c'est
apprendre à connaître autrui qui avait
quand même des contreparties par exemple
la culture d'autrui elle était pas
toujours acceptée par tous
et donc ma réponse a été oui parce que
pour moi la la culture est fait
justement ressortir toutes les
caractéristiques de l'homme c'est à dire
toutes les connaissances l' ajustement
le désir de connaissance et tout
l'attitude à tel qu'il est posé la
culture nous rend elle plus humain il me
sens si vous voulez que autant de sens
anthropologique il faut en parler mais
on peut difficilement passe à côté du
sens esthétique ça veut dire est ce que
l'expérience des grandes oeuvres de
culture ça peut être l'art et ça peut
être le langage nous rend plus humain
c'est en fait nous améliore nous fait
atteindre un niveau d'excellence en
quelques semaines
[Musique]
j'ai répondu que devait renoncer à la
vérité pour avoir des visées le propre
de l'homme ce que j'apprends dû à cette
question c'est que l'homme est libre de
hédé libre de ses propres choix que
c'était plus une question morale on
s'aperçoit qu'avec les réseaux sociaux
les rumeurs se propagent plus rapidement
que les faits établis ce sujet demande
d'articuler amont à mon avis la décision
de vérité qu'est ce que c'est que la
vérité si vous voulez et de quelles
valeurs
si vous voulez le peut se prévaloir
qu'est ce qu'on risque de perdre en
renonçant effectivement à la quête de la
vérité
[Musique]